Eine Quantensuperposition zu messen ist so zufällig wie das Werfen einer Münze, aber wie weit können wir diese
Analogie treiben, bevor sie zusammenbricht? Das finden wir heute heraus, bei Qiskit in der
Classroom. Willkommen bei Qiskit in der Classroom, einer Videoserie, in der wir ein fundamentales Konzept aufschlüsseln, dem du
in einem Kurs zum Thema Quantum Computing begegnen könntest. Jedes Video wird von einem interaktiven Modul begleitet, das in der
Beschreibung verlinkt ist, also schau da unbedingt rein. Heute sprechen wir über eines der Kernprinzipien im Herzen der
Quantentheorie — Superposition. In unserer alltäglichen Erfahrung haben Objekte immer bestimmte Eigenschaften: ihren Ort, Größe,
Form, Farbe — alles an ihnen ist bestimmt und sicher, auch wenn wir als Beobachter es noch nicht gemessen haben. In der
Quantenwelt ist das nicht unbedingt der Fall. Ein Quantenobjekt kann sich in etwas befinden, das Superposition
mehrerer klassisch erlaubter Zustände genannt wird, die bei der Messung zufällig in einen dieser Zustände
kollabiert. Das Messen eines Superpositionszustands ist wie das Werfen einer Münze — es gibt keine Möglichkeit, vorher zu wissen, auf welcher Seite sie
landet. Dieser fundamentale Indeterminismus ist ein unbehaglicher Aspekt der Quantenmechanik, mit dem sogar Einstein
Probleme hatte. Er sagte bekanntlich: „Gott würfelt nicht" über diese Zufälligkeit. Aber wie wir sehen werden, würfelt Gott tatsächlich — oder in
unserem Fall wirft er Münzen. Aber diese Münzen sind gezinkt. Das Messen einer Quantensuperposition mag dem
Werfen einer Münze in mancher Hinsicht ähneln, aber die Superposition selbst ist viel reichhaltiger und komplexer als ein klassischer
probabilistischer Zustand. Um das zu sehen, werden wir darüber nachdenken, wie eine klassische Münze funktioniert, und das mit unserer
Quantenmünze vergleichen, die wir mit Qiskit auf einem IBM Quantencomputer erkunden werden. Zuerst eine klassische Münze. Es ist
ziemlich einfach: Du wirfst die Münze und sie landet entweder auf Kopf oder Zahl, mit 50% Chance für jedes. Prinzipiell könnten wir
berechnen, auf welcher Seite die Münze landen wird, wenn wir die genauen Anfangsbedingungen der Münze kennen und genau wissen, wie
viel Kraft und Drehmoment beim Wurf angewandt wurden. Aber in der Praxis gibt es keine Möglichkeit, a priori zu wissen, auf welcher Seite die
Münze landen wird. Deshalb verwenden wir den Münzwurf als kanonisches Beispiel eines klassischen probabilistischen Zustands, bei dem das
Ergebnis im Wesentlichen zufällig ist. Wenn ich diese Münze tausendmal werfen und die Anzahl von Kopf
und Zahl aufzeichnen würde, würde ich ein Histogramm erhalten, das ungefähr so aussieht. Also haben wir Zählungen auf der Y-
Achse und es kann entweder Kopf oben oder Kopf unten sein, und das
Histogramm würde zeigen, dass es ungefähr 500 Zählungen von jedem gibt, bis auf einige
statistische Schwankungen. Wir können einen ähnlichen Zustand mit einem Qubit auf unserem Quantencomputer erzeugen. Wie der Münzwurf kann
ein Qubit auch in zwei möglichen Zuständen gemessen werden: Null und Eins. Wenn wir etwas anwenden, das Hadamard-Gate genannt wird, auf das
Qubit, bringt es dieses in eine gleiche Superposition von Null und Eins. Hier ist eine
Visualisierung dieses Circuits, den wir Circuit-Diagramm nennen. Hier ist die obere Leitung das
Qubit und die auf das Qubit angewandten Operationen erscheinen als Boxen auf den Leitungen. Das Hadamard-Gate ist mit dieser Box dargestellt,
die mit H beschriftet ist, und die Messung ist mit dieser grauen Box mit dem kleinen Messsymbol dargestellt. Sie sendet diese
Messung an ein klassisches Bit, diese Leitung mit zwei Linien. Da das Qubit in einer gleichen Superposition von 0 und 1 ist, gibt es
bei der Messung eine 50%ige Chance, Null zu messen, und 50%, Eins zu
messen. Wir drücken diesen Quantensuperpositionszustand aus als s = 1/√2 mal
0 + 1/√2 mal 1, wobei die Quadrate jedes dieser
Koeffizienten, auch Amplituden genannt, die Wahrscheinlichkeiten sind, jeden Zustand zu messen. Das Anwenden des Hadamard-
Gates ist also das Analogon zum Münzwurf. Und genau wie wir die Münze tausendmal geworfen haben, um die
Statistik von Kopf und Zahl zu betrachten, können wir etwas Ähnliches auf Qiskit mit unserer Quantenmünze tun.
Wir verwenden ein Qiskit-Primitive namens Sampler, das den Circuit mehrmals wiederholt, um die Statistik
des resultierenden Zustands abzutasten. Mit tausend Stichproben des obigen Circuits haben wir etwas, das im Grunde identisch
mit dem klassischen Münzhistogramm aussieht, bis auf einige statistische Schwankungen. Also ist das alles? Quanten-
Superpositionen sind im Wesentlichen dasselbe wie ein klassischer probabilistischer Zustand, vergleichbar mit einem Münzwurf? Nicht ganz. Das wäre
ein ziemlich kurzes Video, wenn dem so wäre. Um unseren ersten entscheidenden Unterschied zu sehen, probiere ich etwas leicht anderes mit meiner klassischen Münze. Anstatt
sie einfach auf den Tisch fallen zu lassen, wo sie entweder Kopf oben oder unten landet, werfe ich die Münze und fange sie
in der Luft zwischen meinen Handflächen. Jetzt ist die Münze nicht Kopf oben oder unten, sondern Kopf entweder links
oder rechts. Also sagt uns die Logik, dass das auch eine 50/50-Wahrscheinlichkeit haben sollte, entweder
Kopf links oder rechts zu sein. Um Kopf links oder rechts auf unserer Quantenmünze zu messen, können wir das tun, was wir mit der klassischen
Münze gemacht haben — entlang einer anderen Achse messen. Unsere Standardmessungen auf dem Quantencomputer sind entlang der vertikalen Achse,
genau wie die übliche Kopf-oben-oder-unten-Messung der klassischen Münze. Aber wir können unsere Quantenmünze auch fragen, ob sie
Kopf links oder rechts ist. Wir nennen diese beiden Zustände entlang der X-Achse Plus oder Minus.
Dafür verwenden wir das Qiskit-Primitive namens Estimator. Um es etwas komplizierter zu machen: Anstatt ein Histogramm wie
der Sampler zurückzugeben, gibt uns der Estimator den sogenannten Erwartungswert einer beliebigen Observablen des Qubits. Um
diesen Erwartungswert zu verstehen: Sagen wir, du bekommst einen Dollar jedes Mal, wenn die Münze auf Kopf oben landet, und verlierst einen Dollar, wenn sie
auf Kopf unten landet. Der Erwartungswert ist, wie viel Geld du im Durchschnitt bei jedem Münzwurf erwarten kannst. Da
es gleich wahrscheinlich ist, einen Dollar zu gewinnen oder zu verlieren, wäre der Erwartungswert null. Die gleiche Logik kann auf
das Qubit angewandt werden, wenn wir den Erwartungswert von X finden. Wenn wir X auf den Plus-Zustand anwenden,
erhalten wir den Wert +1, und auf den Minus-Zustand erhalten wir -1. Also wenn wir eine
50/50-Verteilung hätten, würden wir einen Erwartungswert von null erhalten. Aber das tun wir nicht — wir erhalten einen Erwartungswert von plus eins,
was bedeutet, die Münze wird immer als Plus entlang der X-Achse gemessen. Das wäre so, als würdest du eine
Münze werfen, sie auffangen und garantieren, dass der Kopf immer nach rechts zeigt. Das liegt daran, dass eine
Superposition nicht nur eine Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung ist. Erinnere dich daran, wie wir einen Quanten-
Zustand ausdrücken: s ist gleich C0 mal den Zustand 0 plus C1
mal den Zustand 1, wobei jeder dieser Koeffizienten komplex ist, was bedeutet, sie
haben sowohl Real- als auch Imaginärteile. Sie sagen uns also über die Wahrscheinlichkeiten, aber sie verbergen auch eine weitere Größe namens
Phase. Ein Koeffizient C kann geschrieben werden als
C gleich Betrag mal Phase, wobei dieses Phi die
Phase ist. Es ist ein bisschen wie die Phase einer Welle oder die Lage der Wellenberge und -täler. Wenn zwei Wellen in Phase
miteinander sind, sodass ihre Berge und Täler übereinstimmen, kombinieren sie sich zu einer Welle doppelter
Höhe. Wir nennen das konstruktive Interferenz. Wenn sie außer Phase sind, wie
hier, dann interferieren sie destruktiv und löschen sich gegenseitig vollständig aus. Um zu sehen, wie die Phase Interferenz
in unserer Quantenmünze verursachen kann, versuchen wir, das Hadamard zweimal statt nur einmal anzuwenden. Klassisch
würde das keinen Sinn ergeben — wenn das Anwenden des Hadamard dem Werfen einer Münze entspricht, kannst du keine Münze werfen, die bereits in der Luft ist. Aber schauen wir, was
quantenmechanisch passiert. Wir wenden also das Hadamard zweimal an und tasten den resultierenden Zustand ab.
Erstaunlicherweise haben wir keine 50/50-Wahrscheinlichkeit mehr. Das resultierende Histogramm zeigt, dass wir in jedem Fall das
Qubit im Null-Zustand messen. Das zweite Hadamard hat also das Qubit in den Null-Zustand zurückversetzt, in dem wir es gestartet haben. Es ist
zunächst etwas schwer zu sehen, aber das liegt an der Interferenz des Quantenzustands. Aber statt
im realen Raum wie eine echte Welle zu interferieren, geschieht die Interferenz im abstrakten Informationsraum des Qubits.
Das zweite Hadamard-Gate ließ den Null-Teil der Superposition konstruktiv interferieren, während der Eins-Teil der
Superposition destruktiv interferierte und verschwand. Lass uns weiter erkunden. Wir können die Phase mit
etwas ändern, das Phase-Gate genannt wird. Wenden wir also ein Hadamard an, um die Superposition zu erzeugen, eine Phasenverschiebung von
Pi Radiant, und dann das zweite Hadamard. Jetzt scheint unsere Quantenmünze immer im Eins-
Zustand herauszukommen. Die Pi-Phasenverschiebung hat die Teile des Superpositionszustands vertauscht, die in Phase und außer Phase waren,
sodass der Endzustand Eins statt Null ist. Das wäre so, als würdest du eine Münze werfen und ihr, während sie in der Luft ist,
irgendwie eine Operation anwenden, die garantiert, dass sie immer auf Kopf oben oder immer auf Kopf unten landet, je nach
Operation. Unmöglich im klassischen Fall, aber nicht im Quantenfall. Was wir aus diesen Experimenten gelernt haben, ist,
dass diese neue Fähigkeit der Quantenmünze auf ihre Phase zurückzuführen ist — eine Qualität, die eine Quantensuperposition hat, aber eine
klassische Wahrscheinlichkeitsverteilung nicht. Also ist der übliche Münzwurf tatsächlich keine so tolle Analogie zu einer
Superposition, weil er nichts über diese Phase aussagt. Ich denke, wir können es besser. Ich mache noch ein
Experiment mit unserer Münze. Die Münze liegt auf dem Tisch, Kopf oben. Um sie auf Kopf unten zu bringen, kann ich sie einfach umdrehen. Das
ist das rechnerische Äquivalent eines NOT-Gates. Sagen wir, wir wollen eine Operation konstruieren, die zweimal angewandt
diesem NOT-Gate entspricht. Wir können diese Operation Wurzel aus NOT nennen. Denke also darüber nach, was wir physisch machen,
wenn wir das NOT-Gate anwenden: Wir drehen es um 180° zum Beispiel um die X-Achse. Also wenn wir die Münze
nur 90° um die X-Achse drehen, gibt uns das die Wurzel aus NOT. Wir haben also
unsere Wurzel aus NOT angewandt und die Münze steht einfach auf der Kante. Jetzt können wir fragen: Ist es Kopf oben oder Kopf unten? Nun,
offensichtlich ist es keines von beidem. Aber wir könnten dem Messprozess einen Schritt hinzufügen, um es zu Kopf oben oder Kopf unten zu zwingen. Jetzt
wird die Münze mit gleicher Wahrscheinlichkeit auf Kopf oben oder Kopf unten fallen. Wieder könnten wir prinzipiell vorhersagen,
auf welche Seite sie fällt, aber in der Praxis ist das schwer genug vorherzusagen, um es im Wesentlichen zufällig zu machen. Wenn ich
messen will, ob es Kopf links oder rechts ist, kann ich sie in diese Richtung zusammendrücken, und das gibt uns wieder eine
50/50-Wahrscheinlichkeit von links und rechts. Aber in dieser Dimension — Kopf vorne oder hinten —
zeigt der Kopf bereits nach vorne, also werden wir zu 100% der Zeit Kopf vorne messen. Also während die X- und Z-
Messungen zufällige Ergebnisse lieferten, wird die Y-Messung immer dasselbe Ergebnis liefern. Wenn wir zurückdenken an das
Quantenmünz-Experiment aus dem vorherigen Abschnitt, erinnert das daran, wie sich die Quantenmünze nach
dem Anwenden des Hadamard verhalten hat: Das Qubit wurde in Z-Richtung mit 50/50-Wahrscheinlichkeit entweder als Null oder Eins gemessen, aber
entlang X immer als Plus-Zustand und nie als Minus-Zustand. Das deutet darauf hin, dass vielleicht eine Münze, die still auf ihrer
Kante steht, eine bessere Visualisierung eines Superpositionszustands eines Qubits ist als eine Münze, die wild durch die Luft wirbelt.
Wenden wir ein Wurzel-aus-NOT-Gate auf unsere Quantenmünze in Qiskit an. Wir haben diesen einfachen
Circuit. Dann verwenden wir den Estimator, um den Erwartungswert der drei Observablen X, Y und Z zu prüfen, was so ähnlich ist
wie das Zusammendrücken unserer Münze entlang jeder der drei Dimensionen, wie ich gerade gezeigt habe. Die Erwartungswerte sind also 0,
minus eins und 0 für X, Y und Z. Das ist dasselbe Ergebnis, das wir
für die Wurzel-aus-NOT-Drehung der klassischen Münze erhalten haben. Tatsächlich gibt es eine präzise Analogie zwischen der
Münze und dem Qubit-Zustand. Jetzt können wir den Qubit-Zustand als Vektor visualisieren, der in die Richtung des Kopfes
auf der Münze zeigt, senkrecht zur Oberfläche der Münze. Kopf oben oder der Null-Zustand
der Quantenmünze entspricht einem Vektor, der gerade nach oben zeigt, Kopf unten oder Eins einem, der gerade nach unten zeigt, und jede
gleiche Superposition von 0 und 1 zeigt horizontal. Die Phase des Quantenzustands bestimmt die genaue horizontale
Richtung, auf die er zeigt, zum Beispiel ob er entlang der X-Achse oder entlang der Y-Achse oder irgendwo dazwischen
zeigt. Dieser Vektor ist als Bloch-Vektor bekannt und bestimmt den Quantenzustand eines einzelnen
Qubits vollständig und eindeutig. Wir können jetzt jedes Gate, das wir in diesem Video gesehen haben, als Drehung oder Folge von Drehungen an der
Münze oder gleichwertig am Bloch-Vektor vorstellen. Das NOT-Gate ist eine Drehung von
180° um die X-Achse. Angewandt auf unseren Null-Zustand oder Kopf oben dreht es sich in den
Down-Zustand oder Eins. Wurzel aus NOT ist nur 90° um dieselbe X-Achse, ausgehend
vom Kopf-oben-Zustand dreht es sich nach Kopf vorne. Ein Phase-Gate ist eine Drehung von Phi um die Z-Achse. Da
Kopf oben mit der Z-Achse ausgerichtet ist, macht das mit der Münze nichts. Das Hadamard-Gate ist etwas kniffliger. Wir
haben es anfangs mit dem Werfen einer Münze verglichen, wobei die Münze unkontrolliert durch die Luft wirbelt. Aber das Hadamard ist tatsächlich eine
kontrollierte, deterministische Drehung der Münze, wie alle anderen Gates. Das Hadamard wird durchgeführt, indem man 90°
um die Y-Achse dreht, dann 180° um die X-Achse. Angewandt auf den Kopf-oben-Zustand
endet es als Kopf rechts. Es gibt also nichts Zufälliges an einem Quantensuperpositionszustand oder irgendeiner
der Standardoperationen, die wir auf dem Qubit durchführen. Jede Operation ist deterministisch und umkehrbar. Das einzige
Mal, dass Zufälligkeit ins Spiel kommt, ist wenn wir entscheiden, den Quantenzustand zu messen. Ob ein Quantenzustand überhaupt in einer
Superposition ist, liegt wirklich im Auge des Betrachters. Wie du wahrscheinlich schon begegnet bist, steht es uns frei, unser
Koordinatensystem zu wählen. X, Y und Z können entlang beliebiger drei orthogonaler Richtungen zeigen. Also
wenn wir eine Superposition von 0 und 1 in einem Koordinatensystem haben, können wir ein neues Koordinatensystem definieren oder eine neue sogenannte
Basis, in der der Zustand rein in die Plus-Z-Richtung zeigt und somit kein Superpositionszustand
ist. Wenn wir also sagen, ein Qubit ist in einer Superposition, müssen wir auch unser Koordinatensystem oder
unsere Basis definieren. Vielleicht verlässt du dieses Modul mit dem Eindruck, dass wir gerade all das Geheimnis aus der Quantenmechanik entfernt haben.
Schließlich ist einer der angeblich seltsamsten Aspekte, der Superpositionszustand eines Qubits, wirklich nur so einfach wie ein
dreidimensionaler Vektor. Aber denk daran, dass die Münze immer noch nur eine Analogie ist und sogar der Bloch-Vektor
nur ein Visualisierungswerkzeug ist. Um die Wahrscheinlichkeiten der Messergebnisse zu berechnen, können wir nicht sagen, was ein Quanten-
Zustand wirklich macht, bevor er gemessen wird, denn um das zu überprüfen, bräuchten wir eine Messung. Wir werden dieses
Dilemma, was die wahre Natur eines Quantenzustands ist und wie das Quantenphänomen der Verschränkung uns helfen kann,
dies aufzuklären, in einer anderen Episode von Qiskit in der Classroom besprechen — ganz zum Thema Bells Ungleichung. In der Zwischenzeit, wenn du
mit Quantenmünzen spielen willst, um selbst etwas über die Superpositionszustände eines Qubits zu lernen und wie man sie kontrolliert,
geh zum Quantum-Coins-Modul, das in der Beschreibung verlinkt ist. Danke fürs Zuschauen, und bis zum nächsten Mal.